[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
sports sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine rugby fédérale 3
versailles a failli créer l'exploit ce
week-end en phase finale dans une
ambiance bouillante les joueurs de la
cité royaume battu servian boujan pas
suffisant pour combler les ss points de
retard du match aller le résumé du match
dans cette édition aviron l'yvelinois
thomas barrau 34 ans a annoncé sa
retraite sportive après plusieurs
blessures contractées ces dernières
années le pensionnaire du cercle
nautique de versailles notamment brillé
à l'occasion des jeux olympiques de rio
en 2016 en remportant une très belle
médaille de bronze il sera avec nous
dans cette émission enfin notre module
découverte il sera consacrée aujourd'hui
au quidditch coup de projecteur sur les
aides less and une équipe des
clayes-sous-bois depuis 2010 est il
pratique ce sport issu de l'univers
d'harry potter l'actualité sportive
c'est maintenant sur tv 78
on va commencer par du rugby ils ont
presque réussi une remontée à d'après
une belle prestation et joueurs du rca
versailles n'ont pas réussi à rattraper
leurs 16 points à 2 retard du match
aller pour passer en huitièmes de finale
de fédérale 3 ils ont battu servian
boujan ce week-end mais il aura manqué
sept points pour monter en fédérale 2
rageant le résumer à des images de
justin brasier un montage de nathan des
idées riches
[Musique]
des fumigènes deschamps ambiance des
grands jours ce dimanche 22 mai à
versailles supporters et joueurs ont un
objectif en tête renversée servian
boujan vainqueur à l'aller 26 à 10 pour
réussir à combler cet écart de 16 points
les bleus emballent le match qui arrive
à faire vaciller les rouges le score à
la pause 18 à 9 avec deux essais
inscrits remontada est en marche la
première mi temps ça a été vraiment très
rude ça est un gros combat très intense
on a on va tout donner saab est passé on
avait quand même un avantage conséquent
au score on était dans la bonne voie
pour accéder à la fédérale 2 et bien
remporter ce match aller retour quelques
minutes après la reprise verseille
poussant ce match retour des seizièmes
de finale de fédérale 3 les versaillais
pensent eux qualifiés suite à cet essai
ils ont comblé à ce moment là leur écart
de 16 points ils sont devant grâce au
nombre d'essais inscrits mais servian
boujan n'abdique pas marc année c'est
remporte la partie avec quelques minutes
de la fin score final 28 19 versailles
échoue donc à sept points d'une
qualification directe en fédérale 2
réaction mitigée parce que c'est c'est à
la fois une grosse déception évidemment
une grosse déception de mourir à sept
points et puis malgré tout aussi une
fierté parce que parce que les garçons
ont fait le job au match retour en fait
sur un match comme ça ils le perdent à
l'aller ils le perdent à l'aller et
s'est laissé ce point de retint et qui
sont ramenés dans les maillages de
servian boujan qui pèse finalement très
lourd à la fin pour se souvenir qu'on a
gagné le match aujourd'hui
après on avait livré une très belle
prestation on s'est envoyé et je pense
qu'on peut être fier de nous et voilà
c'est
faut conserver cet état d'esprit et ce
rythme de jeu et ça peut que marcher
versez y aura une dernière opportunité
de monter en fédérale 2 les joueurs de
la cité royale auront un barrage
d'accession sur un format aller retour
les 5 et 12 juin prochains une seconde
chance à saisir pour les versailles et
leur public n'attend que ça
on va continuer à parler des résultats
sportifs du week end dans les yvelines
notre juriste et bixente merrien
santisteva nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir bixente laissant michael alors
on continue à parler rugby avec vous
mais en effet comme versailles la route
du mlsgp en championnat de france de
fédérale 3 s'arrête au stade des 16e de
finale deux défaites à l'aller et au
retour face à riyom une ville du puy de
dôme en déplacement dimanche les joueurs
de l'entente entre maisons laffitte
saint germain en laye poissy ont perdu
21 17 mené en première période eu la
bonne réaction de la deuxième mi temps
n'aura malheureusement pas suffi mais
comme pour versailles la saison n'est
pas terminée il reste un barrage a joué
très bientôt pour espérer finalement
montée en fédérale 2 l'année prochaine
et ce week-end débuter la coupe ou même
vous bixente vous pouvez espérer
affronter qu'il y avait pire c'est vrai
très tôt cette année d'ailleurs la coupe
de france est déjà de retour ce week-end
nombreuses sont les équipes des
divisions départementales à avoir joué
le premier tour vous savez michael c'est
trajet d'une heure on doit traverser
toute la région allait au fin fond du 77
et bien les joies de cette compétition
plusieurs club saint quentinois l'ont
connue pour la plupart avec succès
montini s'est imposé 6-5 à épiler
voisins étaient en démonstration at il
est dans le 95 7 0 pour bois d'arcy et
coignières et plaisir ça passe aussi
largement seuls les clés se sont fait
peur victoire aux penaltys contre sève
enfin deux clubs éliminés elancourt face
à epinay sur orge et villepreux qui se
déplaçait à clamart une fin de saison
handball masculin à bixente ci c'est
officiel le chesnay handball confirme sa
montée en nationale 2 les chesnaysiens
sont officiellement champion de
nationale 3 depuis samedi malgré une
défaite 30 33 contre abbeville il
profite d'une défaite également des
deuxièmes du classement calais qui reste
donc à deux points des événements bravo
chesnaysiens qu'on suivra bien entendu
sur tv 78 nationale 2 l'année prochaine
un petit mot des autres pensionnaires
évinois de la division affiche une
saison fini également pour les deux
illinois voilà de la poule 3 plaisir les
clés où ils ont achevé leur saison sur
une bonne note des victoires face à
morlaix plus tôt les deux clubs sont
maintenus et terminent respectivement 6e
et 7e de la division du baseball à
présent avec un choc ce week-end au
stade jean maréchal de montigny le
bretonneux le match retour entre les
cougars de montigny et les huskies de
rouyn se jouer ce week-end résultat un
partout comme aux phases aller le roi
n'est ont ouvert les hostilités le matin
l'emportant 2 1 au premier match pour
céder ensuite qu'à trois l'après-midi au
classement après 10 journées montigny et
2e de sa conférence avec 7 victoires
pour 3 défaites devant savini et
derrière rouen qui a huit victoires et
deux défaites les deux face aux cougars
et on reste dans un sport cousin du
baseball à bixente in info venue d'au
delà de l'océan atlantique et saint
michael c'est l'ancienne étoile montante
des cougars de montigny mélissa mahieu
que l'on connaît pour avoir promu le
baseball féminin en france qui
s'épanouit aux états unis depuis 2010 9
elle évolue dans l'équipe de softball
universitaire de louisiane les rats
ginka jones et elle vient tout juste
d'être drafté en onzième position
en division professionnelle de softball
américaines chez les vipers une première
pour une française merci à bixente pour
toutes ces précisions contenues par
reportage que vous avez réalisé la
semaine dernière vous étiez du côté de
feucherolles pour participer au trophée
un sport passion un rendez vous
caritatif avec des stars qui fêtait
cette année ses 29 ans d'existence
regardez c'est la 29e édition du trophée
sport passion comme chaque année une
soixantaine de sportifs de haut niveau
se réunissent ici pour se défier
s'affronter au golf de feucherolles je
suis en présence de la fondatrice régime
gandolfe unis bonjour bonjour alors
comment se passe cette cette édition il
ya déjà ils sont nombreux donc ce matin
on a les 190 personnes d'inscrites entre
les sportifs de haut niveau nos
partenaires leurs invités et quelques
journalistes présents qui joue la
compétition également on est très
content parce qu'avec les deux dernières
années
ça a été quand même assez compliqué
puisque l'art entre les deux éditions il
s'est passé six mois seulement avec les
reports que l'on a eues en 2021 on est
au golf de feucherolles 27 éditions sur
29 ici c'est symbolique pour vous
le golf est parti en fait l'histoire du
trophée sport passion les deux éditions
qu'on n'a pas fait ici c'était pour des
pour des raisons techniques on va dire
donc au niveau du restaurant ici et les
travaux qui étaient en cours donc
c'était plus compliqué une année où on
s'était dit on va aller à saint nom la
bretèche pour avoir deux parcours parce
qu'on a beaucoup de demandes et au final
tout le monde voulait revenir à
feucherolles donc voilà le nôtre au fait
c'est feugerolles qui sont les têtes
d'affiché on peut s'étonner il ya pas
mal de sportifs et les maquis sont
présents on va avoir du thé cuando
présent de la boxe donc on à astrid et
priscilla daigné taux qui sont là on a
aussi une championne du monde toutes
récentes de longboard donc il ya plein
de jeunes nouveau dans des sports qui
ont un peu émergé qui sont présents et
j'en suis ravi parce que le l'esprit du
trophée sport passion c'est ça c'est de
réunir sur une même journée des sports
très médiatisées comme le football le
handball le rugby et des sports un petit
peu moins médiatisé avec des sportifs en
activité donc que les gens connaissent
ou moins qui sont moins disponibles et
faire un petit peu ce mélange qui va
faire que la journée à la fin en soirée
elle est explosive d'un côté nous on va
aller tout de suite à la rencontre des
sportifs merci beaucoup régime
gandolfini d'avoir été avec
on se rend belle donc on est à 2
comprend la meilleure balle donc j'ai un
super footballeur qui a acquis un super
joueur de golf donc ça m'aide c'est un
peu une habitude pas la première fois
que j'y vais faire cette compétition
pour le trophée sport passion des
anciens footballeurs est bien le gall
veulent donc voilà comme on est encore
dans la région on en profite pour venir
partager entre footballeurs mais aussi
avec avec d'autres sportifs
comme nous le disions énormément de
sportifs de haut niveau ici dont
certains qui viennent depuis longtemps
philippe candeloro bonjour bonjour donc
vous vous êtes un peu une icône ici un
parent à l'année dernière mais toujours
présent cette année comment ça se passe
je partie du parcours moi je suis un
arbre ici j'ai dû faire 25 éditions 27
éditions ici à feucherolles c'est cette
année la 29e édition donc oui si on peut
ne pas rater une édition du sport
passion je pense que c'est important
puisqu'on passe tous une très très belle
journée à chaque fois vous attend pour
la trentième édition aussi l'année
prochaine
à bas la 30e faudra pas la rater j'ai
une grande est fini je pense qu'elle a
envie de faire une très très belle
soirée pour la trentième édition parce
que voilà trente ans c'est quand même
beau c'est une belle c'est une belle
réussite ce trophée et on est contents
d'y participer chaque année et pour
conclure forcément on se retrouve avec
le parrain de cette édition bertrand
amoussou bonjour bonjour alors comment
ça s'est passé ce parcours vous venez de
terminer à l'instant oui alors ça s'est
passé on joue pas beaucoup heureusement
qui est origine pour ne faire jouer au
golf une fois par an mais non lance-t-il
magnifique je sais pas comment est fait
mais à chaque fois il fait beau donc là
je pense qu'elle a une connexion directe
à le 06 de de la ola il se passe un truc
mais non c'est génial et avec une équipe
formidable donc comme chaque année
magnifique je crois qu'il nous reste
plus qu'une chose à dire pour conclure
c'est qu'on se retrouve l'année
prochaine pour les 30 ans la 30e édition
du trophée sport passion
on
voit maintenant par les avirons ne le
verra plus dans les bassins l'yvelinois
thomas baruch 34 ans a annoncé sa
retraite sportive après plusieurs
blessures contractées ces dernières
années le pensionnaire du cercle
nautique de versailles notamment brillé
à l'occasion des jeux olympiques de rio
c'était en 2016 en remportant une très
belle médaille de bronze en quatre sans
barreur poids léger thomas baruch qui
est justement avec nous aujourd'hui dans
cette émission on sorte à voir alors
pourquoi cette retraite sportive à 34
ans
bah oui comme tu l'as dit j'ai les
dernières saisons était un petit peu
compliqué je me suis fait mal au dos ça
a laissé la place à une maladie un peu
pénible s'appelle spondylarthrite
ankylosante un homme barbare mais
globalement c'est une maladie
inflammatoire qui touche les
articulations dans mon cas c'est le dos
donc ça génère pas mal de douleur d'un
autre côté j'avais pas vraiment prévu
d'aller jusqu'en 2024 je pensais
m'arrêter après les jeux de 2020
j'espérais pouvoir aller à tokyo dans un
bas dans une embarcation différente des
deux éditions précédentes
ça s'est pas fait c'est avec le report
d'une année rendez la perspective de
2024 beaucoup plus proches me suis posé
la question mais de toute façon mon
corps a répondu pour moi j'arrivais plus
hanquez encaissé le la quantité
entraînement qu'il faut pour être
performant au niveau donc
excusé le sentiment thomas d'être arrivé
là où vous vouliez aller
c'est une bonne question ça non je pense
qu'il reste toujours un petit kit
insatisfaction ne pas avoir réussi à
vraiment
aller au bout de l'aventuré en deux de
couple
ça avait bien commencé et puis un peu de
malchance
et puis souci de physique sont arrivés
donc vraiment j'aurais vraiment voulu
pour tester ce bateau notamment avec
thibaut collard mon coéquipier de deux
sans barreur et de quatre sans barreur
on a beaucoup fait d'entraînement
ensemble m'a pris beaucoup de plaisir à
ramer ensemble mais en a jamais pu
tester le bateau sur une compétition et
c'est un petit regret maintenant sur la
du conduit des résultats que j'ai pu
obtenir
oui je suis déjà satisfait de ce que
j'ai fait
on espère toujours faire mieux et d'un
autre côté j'ai jamais vraiment été
motivée par le résultat j'ai plutôt aimé
le parcours le chemin qui a mené aux
résultats le le plaisir à l'entraînement
au quotidien je l'évoquais précédemment
votre meilleur souvenir c'est peut-être
les jo de rio cette médaille de bronze
ou pas vraiment non c'est pas celui là
parce que parce que derrière et une
période personnel très compliqué
donc j'ai du mal à dissocier les deux
par contre c'est plutôt la médaille de
bronze qui a précédé en 2015 avec
belette en france avec le soutien du
public tout le long du chemin sur une
bonne partie du parcours du moins dans
une ambiance assez extraordinaire que
j'ai pu retrouver et nulle part ailleurs
vraiment faire faire une compétition
internationale à domicile c'est vraiment
quelque chose que je le souhaite à tous
les sportifs
c'est il n'y a pas de comparaison voilà
donc donc j'imagine un peu ce que ça va
pouvoir donner en 2024 pour le jeux
olympiques vraiment c'est une super
opportunité j'espère que les sportifs
franciliens et yvelinois pour en
profiter au maximum et comment le cercle
nautique de versailles club vous avez
été fidèle toute votre carrière vous a
aidé
j'ai effectivement le club dans lequel
j'ai fait l'ensemble de mes coups
d'aviron en fait du premier au dernier
j'ai pas encore donné le dernier enfin
j'espère du moins mais
mais c'est mon club de toujours ça a été
un soutien indéfectible durant toutes
ces années qui ont été loin d'être
évidente le haut niveau c'est pas le
monde des bisounours
il n'y a pas de rien à rien n'est facile
rien n'est jamais acquis et donc c'est
important de pouvoir compter sur une
structure solide qui sait s'organiser
pour faire face à ces défis qui sont
difficiles à relever c'est à côté la
maison aussi c'est complètement à côté
de la maison va essayer d'enchaîner vous
habite encore chez nez et vous entraîne
à versailles ouais tout à fait c'est pas
un hasard si je me suis je suis resté
si je suis resté pas loin s'il me suis
installé pas loin c'est à la fois pour
une question pratique parce que quand on
va s'entraîner deux fois par jour
forcément moyens de transport plus on
gagne de temps et puis et puis voilà
c'est une structure familiale dans
laquelle je me sens complètement à ma
place même si cette année c'est un peu
difficile parce que je suis une période
de transition je sais pas encore
exactement ce que je veux faire je sais
que je vais jamais m'éloigner
complètement de ce club d'ailleurs
question qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant c'est ça va quand même
essayer de reprendre la compétition
alors oui j'aimerais bien aussi mes
soucis physiques je me laisse tranquille
refaire refaire quelques compétitions
avec le club pour ramer avec avec mes
successeurs on a d'un athlète emmanuel
mathieu qui est en équipe de france
cette année en moins de 23 ans ou
seniors on sait pas encore sans risque
de moins de trois ans et sur seniors on
l'espère encore qui a fait de bons
résultats le week-end dernier
en allemagne
donc clairement la suite est toute
trouvée
et puis
si je peux j'essayerai de continuer à
donner un coup de main à la fois en
bateau et puis sur le bord parce qu'une
association sa tombe pas tout seul c'est
tourner avec des bénévoles qui sont là
au quotidien vin quotidien presque mais
plusieurs fois par semaine et puis après
professionnellement je j'ai repris à
temps plein chez mon employeur est né
dix je participe à organiser deux à ma
façon les jeux de 2024 qui ont des gros
enjeux environnementaux et pour lesquels
il n'est dit c'est pleinement impliqué
puisqu'on est un des partenaires de
l'événement depuis quelques mois
maintenant plus de matériel merci à
thomas barrau merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous souhaite le
meilleur dans votre nouvelle victoire si
on espère pourvoir sur les bassins les
bassons m'ont fait par exemple outre
merci beaucoup dans notre module
découverte aujourd'hui coup de
projecteur sur les aides laisse hunt une
équipe de quidditch des clayes-sous-bois
depuis 2010 est il pratique ce sport
issu de l'univers d'harry potter nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre regardée
aujourd'hui je vais enfourché mon balai
pour vous présenter les clips des
ellison qui est basée ici aux caisses ou
moi
je
pour nous présenter ce sport insolite je
serai aux côtés de gilles qui est père
fondateur qui est également coach joueur
qui fait un peu tout ici alors gilles
qu'est ce que c'est ce sport alors le
cou du chien en fait c'est un patchwork
de différents sports on a le rugby pour
les contacter on a le handball pour la
forme du tir on a le cardio beaucoup de
cardio parce qu'il faut savoir que le
terrain qui est derrière nous fait quand
même 44 mètres de long pour 33 de large
donc ce qui est assez long et on peut
aller marquer derrière comme devant au
niveau des buts et on a aussi le ballon
prisonnier donc le dodgeball donc on a
des ballons de football qu'on se tire
royalement dessus donc sert là c'est un
sport de tout ça c'est un mélange de
tout ça est ce un sport mixte un sport
mixte ouais vous le disais depuis la
création de ce sport c'est ça ouais
depuis que ça a été créé aux états unis
faut savoir qu'aux états unis petit
aparté c'est un sport universitaire donc
toucher une bourse pour nous à ce sport
là donc déjà rien que ça et c'est un
sport qui oui qui permet de mettre les
visas hommes et les femmes ont même pied
d'égalité c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
faire ce sport est créé le club
alors on le voit derrière il n'y a pas
de balle et un ca à baton quels sont les
autres différences avec la saga harry
potter et ce sport qui est devenu un
vrai sport oui c'est devenir un vrai
sport en fait il ya une coupe de france
il ya une coupe d'europe et une coupe
d'europe des nations il ya une coupe du
monde que les etats-unis ont gagné
contre la belgique en italie avant de
coheed donc là il ya une nouvelle qui
devrait arriver donc la france est
sélectionné donc elle va y aller aussi
donc cocorico oui ben en fait tout est
différent le ballet on ne veulent pas en
cours avec les ballons de deux ball les
ballons de les cogner à l'essai devenus
des ballons de football le soin fait un
ballon de volley dégonfler qu'on peut
tenir une main et en fait c'est une
sorte de contrainte d'avoir le ballet
parce qu'il faut toujours avoir une main
dessus ou d'avoir toujours entre les
jambes si on l'a pas on est obligé de
toucher c'est que je donc est ce qu'on
va voir sur mon derrière caen caen
ailleurs deux trois trucs et il ya tous
les postes comme dans le coup 10 mai
sauf que ben on a un bandeau pour le
reconnaître est pas une batte de
baseball quand et batteur ou quoi que ce
soit c'est ça la différence il ya
également le vif d'or je crois qui
apparaît en deuxième partie de match si
je peux dire quasiment on va dire
presque à la fin à ce que ça arrive à la
18e minute donc à partir de dix huitième
minute on a donc un joueur qui vient
avec le familles soucieuses short jaune
que j'ai là avec une balle de tennis
dans une chaussette et le but c'est
d'attraper le vif d'or sans toucher le
joueur donc c'est un peu compliqué ils
ont voulu tester aux états unis avec un
drone mais ça n'a pas fait long feu le
drone a été cassée directement donc
voilà et ça dure combien de temps un
match du coup entre 18 minutes et
30 minutes 40 minutes une heure ça
dépend si le 6 le vif d'or et ben on
voit si le videur est bon donc il va y
avoir plusieurs malus qui va devoir
avoir à faire donc ça va être deux à
voir une main dans le dos à se retrouver
à un mètre de la taille des scores ou
uniquement sur la ligne médiane et ça
peut durer autres tant qu'il n'est pas
trappe et on nous on a vu des matchs en
tant que nous les matches qu'on a fait
nous en tant qu elle l'essonne ça a duré
45 minutes une heure une heure trente et
à la fin on a dû abandonner parce qu'on
a dit on n'en voulait plus donc voilà
vous êtes combien ici à pratiquer ce
sport chez les hells on a à peu près
avec les les aides laisse plus les
dragons on a à peu près une 30 à 40
joueurs à peu près qui sont dans le club
et puis on essaye de faire recruter et
ce qui est bien c'est comme ces instants
obligatoirement mixte on met beaucoup en
avant le côté ben que oui il nous faut
dix filles dans un sport comme ça et que
sion dès qu'on a des filles on les
chouchoute alors voilà alors le club a
été créé en 2010 est ce que vous avez
l'impression que le club grandit d'année
en année alors il grandit peut-être oui
nous on va dire il grandit par
le côté l'expérience comprend nous en
tant que joueurs parce que comme on n'a
pas fait très peu de compétition
officiel on est beaucoup demandé
remarque donc on va leur donner un coup
de main aux équipes de mercenaires donc
on leur donne un coup de main donc les
joueurs prennent plus son expérience
personnelle mais en tant que club m'ont
lui-même oui on a su gérer déjà le co
vie en assurant qu on a su rebondir au
plus vite donc ça c'est plutôt bien et
on a réussi surtout m'a donné envie et
la passion à d'autres joueurs et à
d'autres personnes il ya des tournois
qui sont faits
on fait beaucoup les écoles et à
versailles il ya eu moi même et le coach
junior on a fait un tournoi pendant le
centre les mercredis on a fait un
tournoi de coutiches avec les écoles et
les centres et ça a beaucoup plu après
voilà il ya eu le vide y avait tout ça
donc maintenant il faut remettre la
machine en route et pour l'instant ça
marche on est content on est content de
ce qu'on fait on est fiers de notre club
et puis on est quand même le seul club à
avoir un acteur de la saga harry potter
comme parrain donc ce n'est pas
négligeable c'est qui sélestat ne lésine
ski l'acteur qui joue viktor krum dans
la coupe de feu donc le meilleur
attrapeurs du monde pour la meilleure
équipe du monde non enfin non non pas
s'annoncer on est pas on est bon on est
en bas de classement on n'a pas vraiment
de classement parce qu'on a fait très
peu de matches comme vous disais on a eu
la chance d'organiser nos deux premières
compétitions aux clés dans qu'au stade
balle tramini que la mairie des clés
nous à nous aide beaucoup on est très
content d'avoir la lumière des clés avec
nous et non c'est bien on est content et
puis on a beaucoup de presta ont fait
beaucoup de prétendants dans l'île de
france parce que on veut faire connaître
le sport le but de chaque club dans le
cliché de faire connaître le sport si on
peut le faire connaître d'une façon
ludique on va le faire et est-ce qu'il
faut être obligatoirement fans de la
saga harry potter pour commencer ce
sport nous ont pas du tout pas du tout
on a beaucoup de fans mais la plupart du
temps non moins personnellement quand
j'ai commencé le coup dit que c'était
parce que j'avais envie de faire un
sport insolite je sortais du football
américain et je me suis dit j'ai fait un
sport qui sent un peu de l'ordinaire et
je suis tombé sur le quidditch et après
wayne pour pas paraître bête ouais j'ai
commencé à lire l'histoire et puis oui
j'ai commencé à me plaire et puis bon
comme j'ai des enfants mes deux filles
son équipe junior ça m'a permis aussi de
permettre de badauds raconter les
histoires de harry potter et tout ça et
de
de vivre l'univers avec eux donc chaque
est donc tout on peut venir oui même
vous même la caméraman tout le monde
peut venir vous êtes les bienvenus on
accepte tout le monde on en a une séance
d'essai s'ils voulaient venir attester
après l' avantage c'est que bon on n'est
pas là pour pour faire du des
statistiques on est là pour s'amuser
pour apprendre le sport et pour
permettre aux gens qui ne connaissent
pas ces sports la dé pouvoir le vivre
donc voilà
[Musique]
sa bataille on peut le dire un juste
derrière nous yann et jérôme à laurianne
vous vous êtes mis à ce sport il ya tout
juste un an un peu moins d'un an même
c'était en juillet j'ai découvert en
juillet l'année dernière et je me suis
mis en septembre ok pourquoi bah j'ai
bien aimé le concept c'est un mélange de
plusieurs sports etc physique ça fait
bouger il ya une bonne ambiance bon les
balles et ballons arrivent à tard jérôme
jérôme vous avez bien rattraper la balle
en tout cas c'est votre rôle sur le
terrain
alors non moi je suis pas batteur je
suis poursuiveurs je suis je suis plutôt
et je suis batteur excusons
donc moi je suis dans le club depuis
2010 est donc depuis la création il faut
savoir qu'au début c'est pas y avait pas
autant de monde que ça a participé on
était 5 6 dans la première équipe
est en fait c'est le fondateur du club
bagdad qui m'a proposé de faire ça
comment se connaissent et en dehors des
terrains et du sport je trouvais ça
c'est sympa comme expérience
et vous avez accroché et ouais en fait
ça faisait longtemps que je faisais pas
de sport et les sports un peu classique
traditionnelle où c'était pas trop mon
truc là il ya vraiment un côté fun on
vous fait quelque chose vraiment d'être
assez atypique da c'est extravagant
quand on entend parler du sport aux irm
on va courir sur des balais on va avoir
l'air ridicule oui c'est vrai nom
l'assumant fait avec le avec l'habitude
on l'assument mais c'est aussi un sport
très très complet il ya plein de choses
faut faire attention il ya plein de rôle
il ya plein de types de ballons il ya
plein de choses qui se passe autour de
nous il n'ya pas de temps mort c'est un
sport qui continuent tout le temps tout
le temps il n'y a pas de mi temps avec
le ballon et dès qu'un but hop on repart
en contre attaque on s'arrête jamais et
faut être attentif à tout ça ressemble à
du un mélange de de hand ball de rugby
de basket
ça fait intervenir beaucoup beaucoup de
capacités et ses super cardio alors le
président nous a dit que c'était
vraiment pour tout le monde est ce que
c'est le cas alors oui je confirme on
est une équipe très très hétéroclite on
n'a pas ça dans d'autres sports déjà
c'est un sport mixte donc on essaie
obligatoires on a un quota obligatoire
d'un sexe minoritaire donc par exemple
si on a beaucoup de filles il faut au
moins con et trois garçons alors c'est
même très ouvert c'est là où c'est très
très novateur c'est que le ce qu'on
appelle le sec minoritaires ça peut être
aussi bien les garçons qu'on a en
minorité des filles où ça peut être
d'être en jean ou des c'est très très
élargi la définition donc ça c'est déjà
assez attirons parce que ça permet des
mélanges et il ya des jeunes il ya des
vieux
voilà on a toutes les tranches d'âge
vous faites partie des vieux c'est ça si
j'ai bien compris je fais partie des
vieux au lit d'ailleurs je joue avec mes
fils on a créé aussi dès le début une
équipe junior toutes les équipes n'ont
pas d'équipés juniors et du coup les
mets juniors sont en train de passer en
seniors c'est assez plaisant du coup
d'avoir commencé comme ça pour la
déconnade et puis de ba de continuer
puis de faire quelque chose de plus en
plus sérieux au final vrai qu'on prend
ça avec beaucoup de rigolade et b c'est
de la rigolade d'ailleurs ce que l'on
passe vraiment beaucoup de bons temps il
ya vraiment une franche camaraderie dans
l'équipe on se marre tout le temps en
fait on peut pas dire je fais du
quidditch et un plaisir oui mais il ya
la compétition c'est quelque chose de
sérieux les mecs faut penser la gagne
non ce qu'on a toujours un peu le
réflexe de dire ouais mais on court sur
des balais donc ça ça rend un peu humble
mais ça n'en demeure pas moins très très
physique et très sportif alors c'est un
sport qui est quand même assez insolite
en vous le disiez à l'instant jérôme
yann comment réagit votre entourage
qu'on vouloir avait dit je fais du
koulitch dans un club aux
clayes-sous-bois mais en fait moi j'ai
commencé avec ma fille qui est l fans
d'harry potter et qui en fait aussi en
juniors et donc on a découvert tous les
deux et puis on s'y est mis tous les
deux et puis mais après ses balles sont
venus voir ils ont vu que c'était un
sport aussi
un sport plus que ça et du coup tout le
monde est plutôt positivement leurs
membres à vue et tout le monde est
positif et c'est vrai que tout le monde
se pose la question qu'est ce que c'est
exactement c'est vrai qu'on est souvent
interpellée pour savoir qu'est ce que
c'est est ce que vous avez fait la
promotion de ce sport justement bah oui
on est là pour ça on est on veut ramener
plus de monde possible pour pouvoir
agrandir le club et pouvoir faire des
matchs et des compétitions à l'avenir
jérôme insolites on peut le dire pareil
dans l'entourage votre entourage a
plutôt bien réagi si j'ai bien compris
vos enfants sont ici au club ah oui oui
c'est
après s'il ya pas d amis qui vous pose
des questions oui oui disent mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce sport qu'est ce que
vous faites or sur des amis non ils me
connaissent bien sûr des collègues oui
des fois quand on parle des tu fais quoi
comme soir nanao tiens je fais du karaté
je fais ceci ou bo bo je fais du
quidditch hélas ça bloque les
conversations c'est vrai que mais après
il faut qu'on explique
l'ambiance que c'est les gens regardent
un peu des vidéos et quand on explique
c'est vrai que j'aimerais quand même
c'est commence à raconter qu'il ya des
plaquages et comme ça oui en fait c'est
quand même un peu un peu banshee comme
sports jouit
sort avec des bleus on peut ressortir
avec des bleus moi j'ai un doute ardues
mais ça c'est un ballon mal réceptionné
il ya aussi des ballons qu'ils fussent
très très vite faut pas se méfier que
des gens faut aussi que l'état leur faut
vraiment avoir les yeux partout sur tout
ce qui se passe donc oui on peut ça peut
être assez physique par moments c'est
aussi dangereux que dans les films harry
potter finalement ça peut ça veut oui
j'ai moi même le trans planer depuis un
balai fuite à plaquage je me suis
retrouvé trois points c'est surprenant
dernière question qu'est-ce que quels
sont vos objectifs à vous dans ce club à
vous deux jérôme tout d'abord au continu
continuer à prendre du bon temps déjà ça
montre qu'on a c'est aussi quelque chose
qui me permet de continuer à faire du
sport régulièrement sans avoir vraiment
l'impression de faire du sport là on a
on a commencé à monter l'équipe au sens
objectif vraiment défini maintenant on
commence à être plus nombreux à vous et
aux entraînements on commence à faire
des matches la première année on a fait
ça on est exsangue vous pouvez pas faire
peser que des phases de jeu dépasse sans
pouvoir faire deux matches là le but
c'est de pouvoir aller vers de la
compétition il ya des compétitions sans
prétendent avoir les forcément des tops
de classement mais on peut on peut se
défendre face à d'autres équipes on sent
un peu le but quoi et vous du coup yann
et ce serait qu'on arrive à monter une
équipe pour prendre du plaisir tous
ensemble jouer ensemble mais commencé à
faire des matches
contre deux équipes à la semaine
dernière là il ya le week-end dernier il
y avait la coupe de france à angers
pourquoi pas l'année prochaine essayer
de
monter une équipe pour y aller merci à
tous les deux en tout cas vous m'avez
donné envie d'essayer je vais essayer
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
donc là on est bon là même si tu
t'écartes un peu c'est pas grave par
contre si vraiment tu commences à sortir
la des consignes tomber cette musique
est touché par un cognard dombasle est
au dessus de la tête tu vas toucher
telus que vous lui après qu'il n'y a pas
je crois bien de remonter soit on bat
les c ok
[Musique]
ah oui c'est inique
j'ai testé j'approuve ce sport le
quidditch il y environ 400 licenciés en
france et une quarantaine de clubs
maintenant c'est à vous d'essayer
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]